ربما تكون فكره ايقاظ الاموات ضربا من
الجنود وهذا هو الواقع فعلا لكن تاملوا
معنا بقايا هذا الماموث من العصر الجليدي
الذي عثر عليه في المنطقه المتجمده
بياقوتيا في سيبيريا بالطبع لم يتمكن
العلماء من اعادته الى الحياه لكنهم
استطاعوا ايقاظ الفيروسات المتجمده بداخله
ورغم ان هذا الاكتشاف يعد انجازا علميا
مذهلا الى انه في نفس الوقت يدق ناقوس خطر
قد يهدد البشريه جمعاء في اكتشاف سابق تما
كان علماء فرنسيون من احياء فيروس متجمد
خطير يدعس زومبي انتشر قبل نحو 50,000 سنه
الخطر الكبير ان الانظمه المناعيه قد
تغيرت وربما لا تقوى على مواجهه تلك
الانواع من الفيروسات القديمه والاشد خطرا
هو احتمال استعماله تلك البيروسات في حرب
بيولوجيه مثلا
[موسيقى]